we are back and having the exact
conversation that i fantasized about
something that is
very honest very deep very candid
humor breaking it all down thank you for
doing this with me okay there's a quote
that i love
it said trust patterns not apologies wow
i know
brilliant right yeah
trust patterns not apologies do you
think they'll ever change that's a big
part of this process this disclosure
process that couples go through and you
know some people get to the end of the
process and it's where you have to share
the full truth and process it together
and some couples choose to stay together
it did not end up being the right
decision for us and in the end what is
the most important thing to both of us
our child i mean it is all about him you
know when anthony you know anthony was
sentenced to federal prison um for a
little under two years and i my son was
five and i said i am not under any
circumstances gonna take him to visit
his father like i would not put him it
will be too traumatic and i remember we
went away for the holidays and we
traveled we were lucky enough to travel
with the clintons and here we are we're
at this beautiful house at this
beautiful resort we're going out to
dinner every night and the kids are
playing in the beach and playing uno
it's i mean it is essentially fantasy
right fantasy and one night we're at
dinner with this family we had just met
on the beach and the little boy who was
my son's age goes up to his father and
puts his hands up in the air to be
lifted and the
man the father lifts up the son joseph
and and is holding him and jordan turns
to me and just breaks down and says i
want my daddy i want my dad and it was
inconsolable
and that was my like that was my moment
of
you can give everything to your child
if you have the capacity to that is
tangible that is things but nothing
is going to replace the hole in the
heart
that is the absence of a parent and i
made a promise to him the next day i
said i would take him to see his dad and
i did i appreciate that high road
behavior
uh
so much
so here you are sure
in the analogy and metaphors of books
what is your next chapter every day i
wake up and i'm healthy and happy and
have my little boy i have i am grateful
i have gratitude for that because i've
also had an extraordinarily privileged
life i've been walked in spaces and
places and you know that i would have i
would have never imagined and so i do
have the ability to get up and say you
know what
i'm opening i'm opening up my life my
truth and it's been pretty it's been
amazing and i want to hear that from
people who have walked through the fire
um
okay last question woman to women did
you ever tell anthony i love you but i'm
not taking your last name
[Laughter]
it wasn't even
it wasn't any it never even came up it
was not it was not even an issue that i
was gonna take his last name in fact at
one point um
yeah he didn't even ask that's so funny
okay you're here this moment i can't
wait to see what unveils next i thank
you
thank you so much for this
conversation
[Applause]
since this book came out everybody's
talking about it puma abedin for new
york times best-selling memoir both and
a life in many worlds is on sale right
now thank you huma
thank you we'll be right back
[Music]